la oficina nacional de procesos
electorales está casi al cien por ciento
de los votos colocando a pedro que ha
sido con el 19 por ciento de los
sufragios ya keiko fujimori con
alrededor del 13 por ciento pedro
castillo es un profesor que viene desde
el interior del perú allí donde las
encuestas no llegan en su propuesta
supieron conectar con los peruanos del
perú profundo y son aquellos los que
durante largo tiempo han estado pidiendo
un cambio en la clase política en el
rostro de la política y en la manera de
hacer gobierno y por otro lado keiko
fujimori quien tiene un elevado anti
voto debido a su pasado autoritario pero
sobre todo a las acusaciones por casos
de corrupción por los cuales la fiscalía
le pide 30 años de cárcel si bien es
cierto no estaba en el plan de los
peruanos pero que pasó un detalle
importante el ausentismo muchos peruanos
hoy fustigan a aquellos que no salieron
a sufragar en las elecciones del domingo
y que perjudicaron enormemente a
hernando de soto y a rafael lópez aliaga
esto lo ha puesto a la candidata keiko
fujimori para pelear
del perú el 6 de junio francisco gracias
por su reporte